[Musik]
dennis knossalla ist einer der
schlechtesten regisseure deutschlands
er ist das mastermind hinter dem jamaika
verhandlungen
ich habe schon wahnsinnig viele
schlechte filme gemacht aber das hier
ist wirklich ein tiefpunkt ja ich würde
auch lieber mit meryl streep arbeiten
stattdessen habe ich diese für
orgelpfeifen hier man hier steht falsch
ja die mit der hässlichen kathi der
schulter die muss nach links über die
nach links jetzt ja ob sie von den
grünen in der mitte großen arbeitet mit
laiendarstellern und einem drehbuch ohne
jede so auftritt angela ja gibt allen
geflossen und dann wie wir besprochen
haben nicht mit dem rücken zur kamera
nicht so in das haus nein andere hand
zeigen doch nicht wollen dass sich
verpissen soll ja super
ach ja schon alles der seehofer hatten
knopf im ohr sack in seine witze vor er
müsste sie nur nach strecken ok horst
jetzt der witz nachts ist es kälter als
draußen wenn es kühler wird wird drinnen
wärmer
der lange überlegt wie ich das in der
inszenierung von christian lindner aus
der büsche und angela merkel hat letzten
zwölf jahren nur betreut
es war mir dann zu abgedreht
ja ich habe mich dann für eine
klassische notlösungen entschieden als
teure spezialisten
john deere langsam sunshine reggae auf
jamaika demnächst wahrscheinlich nicht
im kino
[Applaus]